ce proverbe là on est intéressant tant
va la cruche à l'eau qu'à la fin elle se
casse
qu'est ce que ça peut vouloir dire
réfléchissons tant va la cruche à l'eau
bon le cru j'ai fait pour aller dans
l'eau c'est normal mais si elle y va
trop souvent elles s'usent et pour un
peu elle finit par se tasser
donc ce proverbe signifie que l'on peut
ne pas se servir indéfiniment des mêmes
objets ou des mêmes choses ou des mêmes
astuces parce que tout finit par s'user
bonjour je ne vous avais pas entendu
entre et je suis en train de lire un
livre ou de proverbes que l'oncle de
casimir son oncle archibald bien en
faire j'adore les proverbes vous ne
savez pas ce que c'est ce sont de
vieilles phrase qui illustre de façon
amusante des vérités remarquez ils ne
font pas toujours croire ce que disent
les proverbes - nous
écouter celui ci les petits cadeaux
entretiennent l'amitié
ça c'est facile à comprendre
un véritable ami n'a pas besoin qu'on
lui fasse de gros cadeaux
mais messi avait fait quand même plaisir
lorsqu'ils voient qu'un ami a pensé à
lui
c'est vrai
allez allez je vous quitte je vais aller
faire une bonne sieste maintenant au
revoir
tiens mais c'est mon livre de penser
maxime
léonard a dû le prendre pour jeter un
coup d'oeil dessus voyons voir où il en
est
les petits cadeaux entretiennent
l'amitié
oui c'est une très belle maxime ça
ça me donne même une idée je vais
appliquer aujourd'hui même oui je vais
faire des cadeaux à mes amis le problème
c'est que j'ai vraiment beaucoup d'amis
pour sa feria j'en choisirai à quatre
par jour voilà aujourd'hui ce sera
françois julie monsieur 10,9 et léonard
je vais acheter le facteur
allant facteurs bonjour oui voilà je
vous explique je voudrais faire des
cadeaux à mes amis non il n'y en a pas
pour vous mais mais si vous êtes un ami
mais mais mais ne vous fâchez pas mon
mot tant pis tant pis pour le secret
voilà vous aurez votre cadeau demain
d'accord bon voilà
pourriez-vous avant de partir en tournée
prendre car quatre cartes postales avec
ma photo voilà c'est ça merci
merci oui ou non je vous attend ici au
revoir facteurs
bon j'espère qu'il arrivera rapidement
pour que je puisse préparer mon petit
cadeau je remette un mot gentil pour
chacun sur chacune des cartes
alors on le voit là celui là il manquait
plus que ça je me suis dans la halle
était criante celle là pour venir
je reconnais là en photo thônex qui
humour et bien ne vous occupez pas de
mon ex qui humour si je dis que je ne
suis pas là c'est que je ne suis pas là
au magazine virtuel puisque tu me
réponds bon enfin si je dis que je ne
suis pas là c'est quoi je n'ai pas envie
de vous voir alors voilà dois je
comprendre que tu me mets à la porte
exactement je saurai m'en souvenir tu
n'es qu'un seul but en mais bien penser
de moi ce que vous voulez mais
disparaissent et je ne vous salue pas
venu
c'est pas vraiment difficile de vouloir
faire des surprises à ses amis
tout ce bruit enfin à l'ombre est ce que
je peux terminer ma sieste tranquille
oui ou non or là là voilà qu'ils
s'emmêlent lui aussi puis savoir si ça
ne te dérange pas à quoi je ne dois pas
me mettre et qui d'autre s'y est mis un
écoutant les honneurs c'est l'heure de
la sieste alors don mais
quand même si tu as tu as dis toi aussi
c'est que quelqu'un d'autre a déjà fait
ce que tu ne veux pas que je fasse voilà
mais qu'est ce que tu racontes et que je
ne souhaite qu'une chose c'est que tu
disparaisses moi qui te croyais mon ami
mais je suis ton ami abc la preuve
d'amitié
la terre sacrée renard alors bon il faut
absolument que je préviens de faire pour
faire quelque chose
alors facteurs oui c'est encore moi non
je ne m'impatiente pas au contraire ne
vous pressez pas oui ou écouter non non
non non je vous retrouve au jardin
d'accord si beaucoup mieux ainsi oui
d'accord
au revoir leona
un bravo et le cash tous maintenant
vous parler d'un ami
c'est terrible
or à chaque fois que je mange de la
salade frisée samedi le hockey
n'a heureusement que je n'en mange pas
souvent
ça résonne dans ma carapace
je ne m'en sortirais pas
peut-être qu'en fermant les yeux très
fort
non ça ne marche pas
la dernière fois je me suis retrouvé sur
le dos au stade où il vit 156e ok
je suis resté 24 heures
le rhône aide je le connais c'est de se
faire tirer la queue
mais tout seul je n'y arriverai jamais
la dernière fois je me la tête coincée
dans une porte par hasard quand ceux-ci
d'arrêter tout de suite mais qu'est-ce
que j'ai eu mal au
nom j'espère commencer d'abord je ne
sais même pas si j'y arriverais
si je claque la porte je n'aurais jamais
le temps de me retourner pourri point
c'est mathieu pas non c'est pas possible
peut-être que je pourrai l'amant
haut n'ont rien à faire
là
léonard écoute moi je vais l'occupé et
toi tu vas lui tirer la queue d'accord
amour
touta bonjour tout à ça va qu'est ce que
tu fais tu regardes 2001
merci merci mes amis comment vous
remercier on est petit trésor
bon ben ça c'est louche
vraiment donc on ne gâchait nos petites
juin or remarque tu lui as quand même
attrapé la queue oui enfin je crois que
j'ai un peu le pion
aux quais
ne fait pas de bruit
j'attends le facteur qui doit m'apporter
des cartes postales il y en aura une
pour françois une pour julie une
formation du srab une pour les anars et
je mettrai sur chacune un petit mot
gentil
et comme les petits cadeaux
entretiennent l'amitié nous serons
encore plus amis après
l'important pour que la surprise soit
efficace c'est que françois et julie ils
ne me voient pas en avant
julie tu tu as remarqué un temps à tuer
changer les boutons de chemise mais non
mais non je te parle pas de saint-just
lige je te parle de kazimiya casimir je
n'ai pas vu de la journée justement il
est en train de se cacher dans le fond
du jardin
son attitude est curieuse il a peut-être
fait une grosse bêtise et ils n'osent
pas venir nous la jouer il est plus
court à l'excès d'habitude écoute le
mieux c'est de l'appeler
casimir
quoi qu'est ce que c'est et de ces mois
ci c'est françois casimir que se
passe-t-il et viennent nous voir ce
n'est pas moi je ne suis pas là
que de réponses à moins que nous ayons
affaire à un mirage qui parle je ne
comprends pas
qu'elle est bien ne fait pas l'idiot
allez viens ici mais on ne pouvait pas
fichés lapin aux gens vous que je ne
fasse pas de voulons simplement savoir
ce qu'ils faisaient là bas au fond du
jardin tu seras mieux de s'occuper
d'autres bombes au lieu de s'intéresser
à ce qui ne te regarde pas
on nettoie un toujours à faire des
leçons de morale tiens regarde nous
ferait beaucoup mieux de t'occuper de
tes ballon il en reste plus qu'à trois
ou quatre qui se battent en duel
d'ailleurs vous m'énervez avec vos
questions je rentre chez moi
[Musique]
mais ça va pas se passer comme ça mais
non facteur ce n'est pas grave henriot
heureusement qu'on n'est pas allé au
jardin bon là c'est entendu je vous
attends chez moi d'accord a tout de
suite
alors bon il arrive encore trop tôt je
ne suis pas là ne t'inquiète pas quasi
mais nous ne resteront pas longtemps
nous sommes venus te dire que tu as
dépassé les limites tu as traité des
amis de façon inadmissible on va tout ça
est bien vrai tu vas pas c'est un
journée à détruire une belle amitié qui
nous unit c'est à toi oui c'est le no
kuni nous partons tout de suite et nous
nous ne disons pas en quoi votre moi non
plus
on
est bien c'est raté
je voulais faire une surprise à mes amis
nous maintenant je n'ai plus d'amis
n'ont pas de chance alors
voici quasiment
jeter a porté quatre cartes postales
c'est par la peine j'ai plus d'amis mais
nous casimir tu as toujours des amis
j'ai rencontré julie françois et
monsieur du stop j'aurais tout expliquer
c'est à ces journées entrée 12 e
ne pouvions pas savoir que vous avez
vous préparé une surtension merci mes
amis tenez voilà vos petits cadeaux
sion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]